i've become
i'm i'm four years sober now
um california cali sober yeah so only
marijuana that's it uh so
and uh so i'm cali sober
and you know
got away from
the huffing duster and doing that and
that and it really ruined my body you
know i had to in the neurons and things
in my brain and i learned so much about
it and i have to take gabapentin three
times a day you know what's gabapentin
gabapentin it's a neurontin that helps
you with you know your receptors and
your brain from the damage that you do
from what happens if you don't take it
you have trouble like connecting words
and not necessarily um but what i did
makes me a high-risk seizure because i
was
doing uh huffing for like 10 years you
know you hiding it from the world
yeah i did nitrous but you did a
computer duster computer duster that
dude that's just like that's just like
two never did that it's almost like i
don't know about nitrous but i've done
it maybe once or something but like
i don't know i don't have you have you
ever tried that i didn't i i was already
sober before i found out about the
computer duster good good what what
what's the high feel like on that it's
like 15 20 seconds and you go right back
to normal but you're like but it's the
craziest euphoric like
high in the world and
it just it's like
you don't really like it is it like
yeah yeah and
and
it's it's just it's really bad and it
ruined my insides and all this stuff and
then you know so
you know i was i dealt with a lot of uh
death my sister you know she she had
just died my full blood sister from a
drug overdose and then my dad died
a few years later
and you know went through some trauma i
released the album and the the year i
released the album was the year that i
went to allah house rehab center
and that and i had already been to betty
ford uh twice
this is 2018 when you released that um
uh 2018 yeah 2018. yeah so that's when i
released it
and then i'm in rehab
and then you know i'm assigned to sony
and i kind of just
ruined everything for myself because
of
you know the disease of addiction
and
it was really sad you know dealing with
that you know um
[Music]
not a lot of people who have if you
haven't been to rehab it's really hard
to understand or see through somebody
who's actually an addict or current you
currently using addict you know
i don't know i think it's kind of
evident to a lot of people if somebody's
loaded i'm so jealous of this
i haven't been able to think about
anything since my girl
wendy from peru
is cheating on me right now with scott
randolph that's how i feel about zelda
she loves scott god
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]